in the dark to like hey guys don't want
to do we are assassins the film of
assassin's creed I just want it to be an
unbelievable ride that leads you into
some action sequences that are dynamic
than they feel really exciting and we're
trying to base as much as possible in
reality
I'm the oldest understandable Michael in
the movie Michael Fassbender's character
is trapped and he has to jump a leap of
faith
jumping 125 feet normally it would be a
digital character that would jump off
Damien's the best so we're going to do
it for real
Justin wants it to be as real as
possible we're going to the real world
we're not relying on visual effects we
start off low the first jump is just a
matter of figuring out the timing of the
freefall the actual footprint of the bag
is only 10 meters by 10 meters so when
you're up there it looks about size of a
four piece paper rather than vertical 7
feet
drop again
in the bag top-heavy so get a bit with
mush on the back of head so I've got to
try and not do that three two one
that's the best bit when you walk off
and go I'm all right yeah